Anish welcome to St Louis welcome to gr
tour what was your last time actually in
St Louis and what was your first time do
you remember how many times you've been
here
before wow I wasn't prepared for this
question I don't recollect exactly what
was the first time I remember playing
here in 2015 it was was a very good year
for me in the grant store uh I almost
won the Tour so I definitely played here
I don't remember if I played before uh
as well and um I haven't been here I
think for a while I think last time in
2019 you
played I have a very bad memory for
years I don't remember like 19 like my
have few reference points in my life
like I know I have to remember my
wedding anniversary that's really
important I also very clearly remember
when I met my wife um I
remember that also because the was at
the regim tournament that I won so I
remember remember the year very clearly
uh so I have few of these markers that I
remember but everything in between is
very vague for me it's getting even
worse you have three kids you have to
remember their birthdays too yes yes no
I mean there are very few numbers I can
memorize and um every different year I
played sful cup is not it's not doesn't
make the cut with all due respect to the
to the event just doesn't make the cut I
just don't remember I I have I have good
memory for chess positions for chess
ideas um for like faces for things but I
have very bad memory for just these four
digigit numbers which are like years and
ratings like I just don't remember like
I 19 18 or like my rating also 26 I
don't know 53 52 I don't remember the
funny thing is you haven't played last
year but it was like it it feels like
you were with us you know commenting on
the event all the time you know this one
you should definitely remember people
tell me everybody feels like I'm with
them the whole time really okay I
remember just your yeah you should just
logo of Twitter sometimes and then
you'll feel some peace from me yes I see
and um um actually um you just come you
coming from Grand Swiss event which was
just finished recently one week ago how
can you assess your participation there
the tournament yeah I was very happy
with the way Grand Swiss finished I won
my last three games but I think um I had
the sort of short run at the Qatar and
Grand swis which are both open
tournaments I played a lot of low-rated
players and I think that run came to an
end I think was reasonably successful
I've gained some um crucial F circuit
points so I think that that's that's
okay I accomplished sort of my um my
goal um for this uh for this sequence uh
but now I'm back to uh the top
tournament with very different um U kind
of lineup and just the your usual sort
of situation where uh it's all very
close in the level and you don't need to
win um so many games um and you you
know sort of the level and the um
tightness is just very different so I
think it's going to be very different
tournament than the one I just played
and I'm looking forward to it yeah I saw
this interview where you said that you
had to adjust even your style because of
of the format of the tournament before
so do you said already you have some
issues with adjustment but I mean I mean
what would it means that now you play in
the tournament of different format you
will you have to be again more stable or
what exactly like like you mentioned I
have issues with adjustments so it means
that probably I will I will finally lose
up here when it's too late and uh start
getting uh getting my ass kicked so no
I'm sure you will figure it out I have a
feeling that you had enough my my uh you
would think that sort of uh you know the
the stability is something I can um
always fall back on but uh you never
know and also I'm looking forward
honestly to play in the rapid and blaz
and also in the classical event I I have
um not too much to lose in a sense um my
main qualification path to candidates is
through Fe circuit and then if I play
this event badly it's not not an issue
at all but it would really help if I
plays really well so yeah I might
um might do you know things a little bit
more wicked
uh maybe I'll like not make like nine Dr
maybe eight this time I mean also I
think people don't know exactly let's
say about these points and the
difference now between you and Wesley
and GES let's say in this F Circle there
is a difference and let's say can you
imagine some can you explain us the best
way scenarios and the worst case
scenarios which can happen let's say
because we know that gr St is a part of
the the circuit right so still there
kind of trying to get the spot yeah of
course like every tournament is part of
that so um uh I mean not to go into
details but like um clearly Wesley if he
has a tremendous performance here uh he
will get the lead um if if I if I
don't um so there's a to play for but um
yeah I'm in a good position let's say
and uh I'm looking forward just to to
play It's better of course to to be
leading right in this sit yeah it's
always better to to win than to to draw
and to draw than to lose that's the what
I learned through my years of experience
that's for sure yeah I think it's a
really good moment to finish this
interview and wish you good luck in the
tournament thank
you